there is a kind of moment there where
especially with something like Coppola
where it's just like
okay I gotta
prove to a lot of people that I can do
this I can prove it to myself I gotta do
it
so
first couple days on set or a little
you know uh stressful but
you do scenes
and
you read the the room you know and
Dexter Fletcher who was the director was
like a [__] hypnotist like he was
just like this incredible
cheerleader where like from
the moment like I was in costume and he
was like you're here made it yeah you're
doing it man yeah you are coping you're
just him you know just be like okay I'm
him I I you're right you know and he was
just like I had this amazing talent to
just instill confidence
so very early on and then I was like I
trusted it I was like okay I don't got
to see playback I'm just gonna keep
doing what I'm doing and
because when I think when you're dealing
with something so
like happens so so much big so much
importance in our business you know like
that some someone like Coppola
I think you have to just like Let It Go
and just play and it's or you'll kill
yourself I mean you're like beat
yourself down
and also like having someone like this
director imagine if you had some
director who was just like an [__] or
wasn't really present they're like oh
let's do another one let's do it again
all right great that's moving on that
you didn't trust then you're gonna spend
the whole feature going yeah I'm going
to be laughing yeah do I suck what's
going on you need we need as actors we
need some Assurance we need some uh some
trust to know that we're on the right
path we're doing the right thing if we
don't get that and we just very few have
the confidence to just trust herself and
no one else you need someone else to
kind of guide you a little bit don't you
yeah you need a good you need to that's
why you want you you want an actor's
director
Dexter it's been acting since he's a kid
like if you're in a comedy or something
and and the director's a little wonky or
they're like a new director
you can at least say hey can I see some
playback you know can I see the dailies
they're more they're more open to that
so so you can at least gauge your
performance you know
um and in the Moment Like especially
it's it's but but with like a drama
there's not a lot of looking at playback
you know there's not a lot of hovering
around you know the yeah
no time really right oh well there
there's time but it's
it's not
it's a different kind of animal it's
like
because
the in comedies it's like you're look
you're
it's it's you get this little audience
and you're standing around the you know
the director's tent and see what's funny
let's see what's working you can see
like you're watching the playback and
it's like it's a group effort you're
like yeah yeah that worked okay let's go
back and do another but it's
okay
I don't know if it's the same but it's
like it's almost too pretentious if it's
drama yeah it's like you can't really
have that audience to go oh yeah that
was really good it's just different like
I remember I did this movie with Steve
Martin and Steve would go to the to the
playback ever monitors every take every
take and you go oh I can go bigger there
I can go bigger and I was like oh wow
look I was learning from him oh yeah
I was not it was called Bringing Down
the House I wore a horrible wig and I
just wanted to work with Steve Martin
and he was lovely but um
yeah he's the best I mean the first day
comes unset and goes tell me about this
Smallville
and uh we hit it off and I'd be at lunch
and go do you mind if I sit here with
you and I go yeah Steve sit down we've
hung out in this trailer he played the
the what is it into the banjo he signed
my jerk poster which is somewhere in
this house